the big thing of course over the last
month has been that elon musk is getting
twitter it's actually happening he said
it then it didn't look like it was gonna
happen we can raise the roof it is
happening and not only is it happening
the guy's gonna put himself as the ceo
this is nuts this is from the daily wire
billionaire entrepreneur elon musk may
be set to include temporary ceo twitter
ceo to his list of titles once his deal
goes through and he becomes the owner of
the social media platform according to a
report from cnbc elon musk is expected
to serve as a temporary ceo of twitter
for a few months after he completes his
44 billion dollar takeover of the social
media company sources told cnbc's david
faber i mean the craziness about this is
not just that he got it like that you
know they tried this poison pill it
didn't work i think all the lawyers of
the shareholders were like we're going
to sue you people into oblivion he got
it
he then puts himself in the biggest
fight like the free speech fight which
is the biggest fight and now he's going
to put himself as ceo like
i love this guy um but there's a little
bit of like
man you're kind of nutty too to put you
know it's like he could put anyone as
ceo he doesn't have to jump into the
fight the guy's also sending us to mars
and building electric cars emily you got
it you got to respect the game on this
guy huh oh yeah 100 he's a very very
busy man and i was so happy to see this
news to see him by twitter and to now
cnbceo is an amazing thing and i think
what's going to be super powerful about
elon is like
he's pretty likable for people on all
sides i mean he bought twitter
immediately is tweeting out how he wants
all of his critics to be super present
on the platform to say whatever they
want to him he wants to make the site
fun again he's saying his next endeavor
is gonna buy coca-cola and coke back in
it he's a very likable guy for
regardless of where you lie politically
and as much as the media legacy media
and all of these other leftists wanted
to come at him and say how dare you
reinstate free speech on these platforms
we don't want the bigotry we don't want
the hate it's not going to show up i
don't think and if it does it'll be
these sort of fake scioppy leftists who
are just tweeting things out from from
bot accounts and i think we're going to
see oh it really wasn't as bad as people
made it out to be and they got
hysterical like they are now with roe v
wade and we're back to normal again so
maybe i can't trust these people yeah
that's actually the point that's the
point i want to make alicia like that
concept right there that we're watching
these people go crazy about roe v wade
they're not sure what they're going
crazy about isn't that exactly what
happened here all the guys said is hey i
just want more people on here people can
say what they want block people if you
don't like them blah blah blah but let's
just open this thing up the way we've
all wanted it to be well those of us
that are roughly sane have wanted to
meet and they just go crazy
it's only democracy if their side wins
it's only free speech if it's their side
speaking um
it's only elon's only good when he's
helping zielinski get free internet to
help their military operations and
people communicate in ukraine but oh my
god he bought twitter now he's the worst
again and he's the fascist dictator it
is so funny and and i have to say like
i'm much more entertained by his tweets
than i ever was about donald trump a
girlfriend i were texting the other day
and i'm like for the first time ever i
have tweet notifications set up before i
used to want to mute the site now i am
anxiously awaiting every single tweet he
sends out because he can actually impact
the scene change that he wants to at
twitter and i just wish i could be a fly
on the wall to see the crying that is
occurring over there over him talking
about being temporary ceo i'm sure
they're freaking out
spencer is he sort of super trump in a
way in that he's the outsider he's the
rich guy he's doing all the things that
nobody else was willing to do and but
he's doing it in a more sort of calm fun
whatever way like without the grab them
by the you know what etc
yeah i think there's a lot to that and i
especially think the comparison is close
when it comes to how conservatives are
responding to this you notice we're
always accused of like hero worshiping
trump or whatever being slavish admirers
but most conservatives if you talk to
them they don't put their trust in
princes right they we don't elevate
people up onto that pedestal and musk
listen has said some stuff about the
future of technology that gives me the
heebie-jeebies a little bit he's not
like you know somebody who believes
everything that i believe but he is the
man for this job what did we need we
needed a super powerful tech billionaire
to fight with these guys on their terms
um he obviously drives all the right
people insane when it comes to free
speech and this is exactly what he
should be doing i personally am getting
tired of so much winning i mean he rolls
in like the fact that he's taking over
as ceo indicates to me that he intends
to do something which i really think is
important that he should do which is to
fire the people who think that he's a
fascist nazi terrorist evil doer right i
mean never mind he's going to let them
on the platform of course but you
shouldn't i mean all these guys in news
rooms do this thing where it's like well
my employees are staging a walk out it's
like great they work for you fire them
like it's fine you know and i think that
musk's takeover as ceo kind of indicates
that he wants to take that kind of
strong hand you know i have my
reservations about some of the guys
beliefs but when it comes to twitter
elon take it to the moon to be clear
when he fires all these people i can't
speak fully for rumble and locals
anymore but we will not be hiring any of
these people i'm pretty sure i can say
that
um
this idea though that you know they're
it's consistent with their idea that
that words are violence but violence is
not violence right so if you burn down a
target in the name of social justice
that's not violence
but if you misgender somebody that is
violence so we shouldn't be that
surprised that they're so bananas right
now right
no we shouldn't be surprised at all and
i don't think elon's gonna have to worry
about firing them the brilliant thing
about leftists is they won't work for
him they will just leave and they will
have this mass exodus from the company
so that's what i'm looking forward to
seeing but yeah it's like alicia said
they'll say anything so long as it's in
their favor so long as it supports them
you know they don't support
vigilantism when it comes to citizens
taking the law into their own hands but
they're totally fine with vigilantism
when it comes to this roe v wade leak
they're not fine with protests and riots
when they look at january 6 and
everything that happened there but
they're totally fine when it again
supports roe v wade or the george floyd
riots in the streets everything is just
going to be wishy-washy so long as it
supports themselves and luckily i think
what's happening now is normal people
who are maybe in the center classically
liberal conservative who have just been
really quiet they're just sitting there
watching this all play out i think young
people are watching this all play out
too and go you know i'm not even even in
my puberty stage i am not as ridiculous
and emotional as this and i can't vibe
with it so i'm hoping that's what's
happening is that we're just having this
revolution in america of normal people
who go i cannot put up with this for
much longer a normal people revolution i
like that
you